everyone here saw the fight obviously oh
yeah yeah [__] dude yeah stand up late
stayed up late yeah okay uh thoughts
about the fight
son I didn't know Izzy was playing
possum and then I was so [__] worried
and I feel kind of bad because my wife
was like why are you acting like you're
fighting and then I was like because I
hate it when people do the sun let me be
into something then I got into Karen you
acting like you made the purse with
Chanel
you didn't make the purse with Chanel
you like the purse but then I got
insecure and I was like you don't
understand he could die in there and
then she got super worried and then she
everything she was like freaking out
because she was like oh my God this guy
could die and then I spent 30 of the
fight being like no but he's actually
too good of a fighter die in there
the same thing here in Top Gun though he
was like no Tom Cruise could die in
there like it is scary it is
intimidating remember when I was
watching the the last dance and my wife
recorded me giving her the rules and
then I told her I was gonna jump out the
window I had enough I said I had enough
no no I said I said I'm gonna go watch
it at the studio I'm Gonna Leave You
right now I'm going to the studio to
watch but you already know what happens
to Michael Jordan yeah dude you already
know what happens yeah that's how
important it is that's how important it
is you know what happens at church no no
uh-huh sometimes he'll freestyle church
every Sunday you know the story no but
he'll add some freestyles
he made a Bordeaux this weekend last
weekend it was a Merlot it's the little
things bro it's the spice of life anyway
you could know the ending for something
and still be in you know and enjoy the
experiment whatever
stroke in the middle of it yo shout out
to uh the Mario Brothers movie we're
gonna get back to that in a little bit
but um
Izzy Victory is he Victory everybody
collectively lose their [__] minds
when he got their KO yeah my dog started
shaking I was screaming so loud he like
thought I was and then my wife was like
yo people who didn't want to fight think
you're beating me up right now because I
just kept let's
flip going nuts that's what you would
sound like if you were beating her up
yes
[Laughter]
you don't need to do an end of Fight
promo if you're beating your wife you
know what I mean you don't be like I'm
the cream of the crop yeah
[Laughter]
that's abusive if you do it you don't
celebrate yeah because that means you do
it all the time yeah but if you do it
for the first time you gotta dance
around we competing you're gonna use
that you gotta drag her body to the
middle of the living room and then sit
on top of her and do this [__]
people just celebrating your last
moments of Freedom right you got to get
it off you gotta have a story for the
boys in jail yes yeah you just hooked
her off one time and then that's it you
do a post-fight interview like honestly
he was looking good in the first round
she was she was going for it you know
what I'm saying
I mean yeah you could do that
it just died
[Music]
tell us how you feel after that
she was she was good when she was put up
a fight
I'll put charge of misery right now
that's the hardest part of fighting no
one ever talks about that the fight is
the easy part he's gonna keep going
that [__] is tricky you gotta have your
words all organized anyway
yeah Lee bruh did you get beat up by
your wife I'll be honest man it was a
tough fight bro I'll be honest this is
good all right so
in the fight
Izzy said he was playing possum at the
end yes
part of me is like I believe you Izzy
[__] the other part is like [__]
he caught you with the mean leg kick
right before he landed a couple punches
right before now I will say this there
was another time where Pereira
was closing the distance on Izzy and
then Izzy
put his hands up and then started
swinging with him and just exchanged
this was earlier in the fight but that's
I think he went into it like he leaned
into it and he got caught but still he
exchanged it and I I remember at that
moment I was like oh [__] hold on he's
gonna trade with him yeah because that's
a brave thing yeah yeah the guy who has
knocked you out once cold yeah last time
you guys fought KO basically the same
way like up against the [__] gate
like trying to slip punches exactly
right so that was the moment right there
like The Knockout it was one of the most
Brave things I've ever seen and also
like one of the most like a cognitively
aware things I've ever seen like he gets
hit by a few different punches he gets
need basically in the [__] cheek
right massive knee he gets a left hook a
deadly left hook that hopefully he
blocks a little bit with his hand and
then he does this great thing
he sees that pereda is loading up the
left hook again and he does this quick
little pop jab and then that perfect
right hand comes over he rocks him and
he falls in the same way when he knocks
him or we almost dropped in the first
round the other fight but this is the
craziest thing the second right hand he
lands I've only been able to see the
punch at .25 speed yeah the punch does
this magical thing and this is where
like I don't know if he's watched so
much anime it's starting to like
manifest itself but like and I mean this
sincerely if you watch at regular speed
you see the punch get thrown and then
from about here to when it hits his head
just disappears I don't know if it's a
glitch in a camera I don't know what the
[__] it is but if you watch it regular
speed you the punch starts here
disappears and then ends up on his head
were you watching them
I had to bring it down to 0.25
it could be my my ESPN account I gotta
talk to the to the mouse about that at
home we got your stream up here see what
I'm saying yes
all right let me pull that let me pull
it up all right okay this is 0.25 though
right or whatever point no
huh that's just buffering
now the quality of this is so bad I
can't believe you're actually playing it
it
I I've watched it 0.25 speed that's the
only speed where I can actually see that
second right hand connect it's the
fastest punch I've ever seen from yeah
yeah and and then game [__] over and
then celebration crazy unfucking
believable the celebration is like I
mean he's not a human being anymore he's
just an anime character bro the whole
storyline I mean
I I'm just trying to understand the
Liberation you feel right if you look
back to our first interview with him
I asked him because I didn't even think
I knew but I asked him I was like have
you ever been ko'd he goes Yeah by some
guy I'm not even going to mention his
[__] name I remember that okay I
remember that right I went I think
looked it up afterwards I was like who
is this [__] this beaten is he
right and I saw the kill and
imagine that you're on top of the world
you're I think at one point he was
probably pound for pound number one
everybody's going nobody can beat you at
middleweight it's absolutely impossible
you're the [__] King but you know in
the back of your head there's a guy that
got the best of you yeah you've probably
gotten the best of every other person
that you've fought maybe you lost a
shitty decision maybe you lost a shitty
decision in China where [__] is corrupt
but there's a guy who ko'd you and you
haven't gotten that get back in
and then you fight in the UFC and he
takes everything you work for and now
people start to question you other
Fighters are starting to chirp and just
like last time you were beating him the
whole [__] fight exactly you were you
were a minute away or a minute and a
half away or however long away from
actually getting that you know getting
that what is the Pervert what was the
term getting the monkey off your back
right I'm glad you said it yeah so so
and then to go in there and not out
Point him that's what I liked about it
yeah he didn't win a decision
so yeah how did it judge his hands yeah
night night of all the weight class all
the belt holders in every weight class
he's beaten the most people did you see
that stat whereas like he beat not like
nine finishes of nine different Fighters
whereas every other belt holder and
every other weight class is like three
finishes of people in the weight class
yeah because like spells be moving
around so much but it's just dominant
you have to be dominant over a long
period of time right if you're fighting
three times a year you have to fight you
have to hold that belt for three years
to fight nine guys that's if Dana White
was even saying afterwards he was like
you know most guys they'll fight maybe
once or twice in here once they get the
belt you know they're living a good life
why do they want to go out there and
risk it he goes Izzy's out there three
times a year yeah anyway it was just
this amazing and I can't imagine that's
why I really wanted to talk to him I was
like what does that feel what is the
liberation of slaying the dragon of
knowing you could beat a guy he's
beating you three times he's taken
everything and then you finally beat him
and in convincing fashion he can't say a
single thing he's unconscious knocked
out what he did to you you just did to
him what is that feeling yeah I'm
mocking his kid right
how does he remember all the tags that's
what I'm saying that's right yeah how
after a fight you have the mocking of
the kid you have like this amazing
speech that you give [__]
motivational
literally did he do the bone arrow every
time Pereira every time every time so he
had that lockdown oh yeah because he
practiced The Improv if you look at the
Improv from just a purely comedicated
but it's like perfect
I wonder if he did three because he got
beaten three times yeah he gets the ball
three arrows he gets the bow and the
arrow who would do that yeah there's a
great there's got no Trill effects or
something like that yeah he did this
amazing like he adds animation to the
video puts actual arrows
it's a perfect improv like he doesn't
like throw the it doesn't disappear I
want to know the moment what he's
thinking the moment he sees the opening
for that first that jab that Lefty
throws when he sees it when he sees that
connect and then he connects to right I
want to know his entire thought process
as he's seeing I'm all of it that's my
imagine I'm imagining he sees potato
loading up the left again yes because
potato lands a big left but he blocks it
and then he sees him dipping to load it
again and then it is just lightning fast
and I think it's one of those things I
think he made a decision and I want to
[__] talk to him about obviously but
like I think he made a decision which is
if we get in close he's going I'm not
gonna hold his hands remember that's
what he was doing before oh yeah we're
swinging yeah and he did it earlier he
got caught but I was like oh [__] he
wants some Bang
a bang but he also is keeping his guard
up and I love that's a difference like
usually he'll be like this with it but
he was like this oh we're doing this
yeah I'm locked in and I'm willing to
take one to give one and he got caught a
few times by Panera and the chin held up
and I wonder if you get some confidence
going okay he's Hit me hard he kicked
him padetta kicked him once in a [__]
head and he got caught but he you know
kept this cool yeah but I wonder if that
was in Camp it was like yo I'm going out
if I go out I'm going out on my shield
because you have to understand when you
decide to exchange with somebody in that
moment that's an all-in hand in poker
because if you get caught someone bigger
than you stronger than you and keep in
mind he's not imagining it's over yeah
he's felt it be over yeah a bravery of
sitting there in that moment and going
this is a 50 50. either I'm gonna hit
him and it's and it's lights out or he's
gonna hit me and it's lights out again
and he just decides to do it I'm
prepared to Die
part at The Knockout it was I think I
think as he did get hurt and that's why
he moved back but but I thought he was
like really hurt so I was like I think
Izzy still had all his like wherewithal
about him so that's why like that first
check uh jab was just to see the
distance that's why the second one was
perfect yeah getting hit in your leg
doesn't Daisy yeah it doesn't Daze you
so he's all there he's just a little bit
was it incapacitated yeah so he's always
incapacitated so he can think he sees
the punches coming he knows everything
that's happening but he just can't move
and then when potato walked into that
trap yeah yeah now true majority I don't
know if y'all saw true Jordan did a
great breakdown of the first the end of
the first round of the last fight oh
yeah and then this so I think Izzy was
thinking I had this [__] in the
first round if that round is three
seconds longer one second longer I want
I KO this well well well can I tell you
one thing and Izzy even said this
is he did something different this time
so last time he hits him with that
overhand right and he'd been reaching
for that overhand right in the first
round too he'd be getting close but
today was keeping distance he hits him
with that big overhand right right
wobbles him what does he do in the first
fight he fakes a right and then he
throws a hook yeah this one he said no
double it up double it up give it to the
next person this one is what hurts you
and you're getting this one again and I
remember when he was on the Pod he was
like I don't know why I went for an
uppercut and then a hook I like faked an
uppercut and went for a hook he was I
should have just thrown the straight
right or the looping right over and he
[__] did it this time yeah yeah ah
what a [__] I love that he didn't really
take cheap shots afterwards he finished
them and then he went for the pound and
then he was out and he was like all
right that's all I need to do he got he
got he got one he got one but he pulled
back in the second one was like that's
all and he said I put everything into it
he was like that was he said that was
from the gods oh my God no that was
crazy yeah amazing but I didn't even see
it as like violence I saw it as like uh
letting everything out here and I'm
[__] winning yeah I'm not his guy's
not getting Saved by the Bell and every
piece of like negative emotion I felt is
going into this yeah
I didn't think it was any like malice or
wanting to hurt him I think it was just
I have to win it all